john bolton was former president trump's
national security adviser and previously
served as
u.s ambassador to the united nations and
he joins us now ambassador good morning
thanks for being with us thank you for
having me
uh a lot to talk about but let's start
with cuba you've said the u.s
should show strong support for the cuban
people
do you believe the president should be
advocating for regime change there do
you see this
as a national security threat
uh yes i do look ev ever since the cold
war russia has had a significant
interest in what happens in
cuba they've used cuban surrogates in
places like venezuela to ensure the
chavez maduro dictatorship there i've
talked about the troika of tyranny in
the western hemisphere cuba venezuela
and nicaragua
i think these demonstrations in cuba
which uh
experts say go back to the early 1960s
in terms of the size and the
the spread all across the island i think
this shows real dissatisfaction not
with temporary circumstances but with
the regime itself
and i think we've got lots of cuban
americans who can have a lot of
suggestions about
how to put pressure on this regime and
let the cuban people have their freedom
back
uh ambassador i also want to ask you
about afghanistan because the biden
administration is pulling troops out
uh by the end of august we're going to
be out of uh be leaving afghanistan
you've said that that's a mistake across
the board
that war has cost by some estimates in
in excess of two trillion dollars
is the price of leaving going to be even
higher than that do you think
well i think that's the risk look not
all of that money was spent on
uh on actual military hostilities and
the reason we went into afghanistan was
very clear because we were attacked
on september the 11th the reason we've
stayed in afghanistan
for 20 years is not out of charity it's
not to make afghanistan a nicer place
it's not even principally to defend
the government of afghanistan it's to
defend american
civilians against another terrorist
attack now if we
when we withdraw and nato along with us
uh people are pretty confident that the
taliban are going to take back over
all or nearly all of afghanistan there's
a high likelihood that al qaeda and isis
will once again
take central sanctuary there and
threaten us with terrorist attacks
that's the cost we should be looking at
not not looking at what it is today but
what we
prevent what we have prevented by our
sustained presence there
you think we accelerate the risk of
another 911.
i think that's the prospect if the
taliban take back over and i don't know
any
serious observer who doesn't think they
will they've maintained their ties with
al qaeda
isis and other terrorist groups we
haven't even heard of yet
will take advantage of the isolation of
afghanistan
and set up bases there we're there as an
insurance policy to protect america this
is not
a charity project for afghanistan the
opponents of our being there
have treated it as if we're trying to
make afghanistan into the switzerland of
central asia
that's not the purpose the purpose is to
protect america there
rather than to have to protect it in the
streets and over the skies here
you mentioned the russian influence uh
in cuba i want to ask you
about uh the buy administration's
approach towards russia
uh his predecessor who you worked for
you said in an interview last year that
you believe vladimir putin putin thinks
he can play president trump like a
fiddle
do you think mr biden has had a better
approach
well i think they're still getting
warmed up but we have had a summit
between biden and putin biden supposedly
told putin to cut out the cyber attacks
that was followed by a significant
ransomware attack we don't know whether
biden has
taken retaliatory measures i certainly
hope he has in cyberspace
but i think our policy on russia is
still very ill defined and
cuba is not a place to give the russians
a break
what do you think the president should
be doing with mr putin's particularly on
cyber security
well i think he should be beefing up
american offensive cyber capabilities to
create
structures of deterrence against what
the russians are doing putin has played
a weekend very well this is a form of
asymmetric or hybrid warfare that they
wage against the united states
we need to do a lot more just with
respect to russia but with respect to
china
iran and others who are engaging us and
and we're not adequately prepared
former uh former president trump uh your
former boss
uh won the straw poll at the cpac
conference
uh i think you got 70 percent of the
vote um
the only person who was even close to
that was ron desantis with 21
would you vote for president trump in
the next election or
for governor desantis
well i i don't think president trump's
going to run for re-election in 2024 he
may talk about it incessantly before
then
but i've had two polls that my super pac
has done already one national poll one
in new hampshire that shows
trump's support among his base within
the republican party
slipping which i don't think is
receiving adequate coverage
and i've got a poll coming out in the
next few days that will show
continuing splits and problems within
trump's base
i think trump's support is exaggerated
and i think people are making a mistake
if they think it's going to remain
durable so if
if he were the nominee though would you
support him
no and i didn't support him in 2020 i
don't think he's fit to be president
it would be a disaster for the
republican party to nominate him he
would lose
overwhelmingly he has very very little
support among
independents and he could take down an
awful lot of republican candidates for
the senate the house
and state and local elections ambassador
bolton thank you very much for being
with us this morning we do appreciate it
yes we do ambassador i guess you and the
president won't be going to lunch
anytime soon
ambassador bolton no christmas card all
right
thank you sir good to see you